Woff!
My fellow babe goons, I'm so sorry to keep you all waiting.
My fellow babe goons, I'm so sorry you must all be so lonely
at this day.
hello everybody I'm sorry for being so late I have such a
good excuse for all of this it was because I was about to
take a bath so I was stuck in the groomers for so long but I
got a lovely rose for my lovely babe goon sorry sorry I
still have my coffers sounds like i'm laughing um mr broken
bun thank you for the super chat thank you thank you dad we
are finally back of course of course of course everybody i
even learned some cool new dance moves you want to see wait
give me a sec whoa whoa whoa oh whoa i didn't know i could
do that give me a sec i also have another excuse why i'm
late i was taking dance classes for my babe goons out there
don't worry give me a sec let me let me pull it up i learned
this dance just for my babe goons watch this
wait am i doing it wait wait let me give me a sec i'm
Give me a sec.
I thought it would do it, but it did.
But thank you for coming to my birthday.
I made a special letter just for all of you guys.
me a second let me let me pull it out it's in my pocket
somewhere right here
let me let me let me grab it i make this special special
invite just for you my beautiful babe goon you're invited to
my birthday party from dad doki amber doge that's me that's
me so will you will you come with me on this magical journey
um our special day
come with me take my hand babe goon come on take it And then
we We can go on all the walkies in the world Just you and me
Babe Goon
Doll, thank you for the super chat Thank you, thank you
Tucked you such a dork I love birthday what do you mean
dokey she left me here by myself no chaperone just me and
you watch this oh i can chase my tail did i get it did i
call my tail
do you think i got it i think i got it
I'm so happy now.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Doggy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Mew, thank you for the super chat.
Mwah.
Don't, don't, wait, no, dad, so handsome in 3d really do you
guys really think i'm handsome oh my god i know all the
ladies love me but it's just you and me baked food i chose
you to spend my birthday with you just remember that i could
have had any other babes out there but i specifically picked
Yes, you.
I'm talking about you over there.
Yes, that's right.
You.
I'm talking about you, babe.
Eating.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Mwah.
Bear.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, I can do a Jojo pose.
Watch this.
Yeah!
Oh, it doesn't even look like I'm jumping, but I swear it's
just my legs are very short.
But look, I can move it up and down.
It's just my legs are very short.
This is me doggy paddling, by the way.
Oh, where was I?
Sorry, I lost track.
Oh my god, so many babes today.
spending their special, our special day with me.
Zalphius, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Jen, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I got some spaghetti.
Oh, I love spaghetti.
I love all types of food.
So like any food you get me, I need to sit down.
I'm sorry I've been standing I've been I've been standing
out here in the streets of a parent of the streets of Tokyo
for so long waiting for for you guys to show up to my
birthday party I was standing trying to figure this out I
was trying to figure out my camera for so Darling, that's
why I was late, you know, also because I was at the grooming
and I've been standing.
Look, my legs are so tiny.
Look at them.
Look how tiny my legs are.
Do you really expect me to stand all day?
What kind of date is this?
You want me to stand all day?
Come on, you gotta let me rest a little bit.
We got all night, babes.
We got all night.
I also need Hydra.
Give me a sec.
I need Hydra, too.
All right, I'm good.
I'm good.
All right.
Let's see.
Where was I?
Lear Bear.
Thank you for the super chat.
Mwah.
Peek dad content.
Anytime I'm on the screen, baby, I'm always peek.
next see thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
fudge top yeah unlike dokey unlike dokey bird i read all my
super chat because every single one of you is special in my
heart you're all so special i don't want to miss any one of
your Super chats.
But stop.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my dad.
You're so handsome and charming.
Of course, baby.
I hope tonight doesn't end too fast.
Oh look.
There's a hotel right there.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
Dad is kind of creeping you.
you mean darling what do you mean baby i'm not creeping you
out i got you a rose that matches how beautiful your eyes
are lord kerosus thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you
um simple-minded thank you for the super chat thank you
Dad, what about that Poodle down?
Oh, fuck that bitch.
I swear, if I see that Poodle disrupting our alone time,
that bitch is going to get something.
That's for sure.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Mr. Mifflavikins.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I want one, too.
Dad, don't worry.
There's plenty of dad to go.
go around.
I mean, should I give you guys a little 360?
I mean, oh, let me, oh, all right, let me, don't.
Yeah.
Like what you see.
That's right.
Oh, watch this.
Look at that.
I can stand on one foot.
That's right.
Oh.
Yeah.
A little sneak peek for tonight.
Yeah,
ladies and men.
Dad, can you flex that muscle eating?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Of course.
Now you also know why I was late.
I had to go to the gym real quick in the morning, you know.
Gotta do my pushers.
Watch this.
One, two, three.
yeah you like that yeah three whole push-ups that's right
three whole push-up get up get a dog that can do that so
strong i know zekra thank you for the akasupa thank you
thank you oh
it's four kisses for you dad is that rose specifically for
me babe of course it is babe who else would it be for just
you all right wait there was something i want to see if it's
let me just see if i can get this to work like i had some
cool dances but then i didn't know why it didn't play i mean
i had some cool dances that like i really wanted to show you
guys it's pretty funny i don't know let me figure out how to
get this to work i said this no but how do i do this
uh oh wait i figured it i know i know watch this okay all
right watch this guys okay guys i can that's pretty neat i
took lots of dance lessons for this i just gotta remember
how to do it Watch this, guys.
Uh.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Okay, watch this.
All right.
Watch this, guys.
Uh.
Did it work?
Did it?
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Watch this.
I swear it worked before wait wait wait I swear it worked
before I don't understand okay give me a sec okay I'll
figure this out later guys I'll I'll figure this out later
apparently I didn't know how to do this
I'm sorry I had a high performance anxiety you know it's
been so long since I could move like all in my bodies and
I've been stuck at home for so long but like today it's just
you and I babe going um not unshapperoined
no chaperones to see us not great babe rice thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you it's okay dad it happens
to everyone sooner or later there wait let me let me google
this real quick uh
it's okay it's okay it's okay i have google i have google
it's okay i could do this Uh...
Huh?
Wait, wait.
Give me a sec.
What?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
I can figure this out.
What the?
Oh!
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Huh?
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Huh?
Where is it?
Wait, I'm figuring it out.
Wait, guys, wait.
Okay, so it's this?
No?
Oh, oh.
It's...
What?
Guys, I swear to God.
When I figured this out, it's going to look so cool.
I just I just need time I just give you a set it's gonna
look so cool when I figure it out I just I just need to
figure it out wait up what
okay okay okay wait wait wait wait wait wait I swear to God
I I I swear to God I can make this work music.
Oh.
It's this, right?
Why is it empty?
I understand.
What do I have?
Wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
What
the fuck?
I swear to God, I worked so hard, but like, I'm so confused.
I'm so confused.
so much reading.
I'm trying to...
I swear, it's so worth it.
When I figure it out, it's so...
I swear to God.
I just need to figure it out.
I just need to figure this out.
It's so funny.
I swear.
Why aren't I doing it, though?
It's so funny.
I just...
need to remember how to do this it's so funny please believe
in me it's really really funny i swear i just don't remember
how to do it wait okay what if what if oh oh i know i know
watch this guys Okay, all I have to do Okay, I'm T-posing
But guys, it's worth it Watch, I figured it out Okay, watch
this Guys, watch this Bump Bada-dada-dada-dada-dada-dada
Bada-dada-bada Bada-dada Bada-dada
And then, look, look at all these dance lessons I took just
for today, guys.
And then there's this.
I told you, babes, I went to all these dance lessons just
for you on our special day.
I thought there's more.
Watch.
Bumpa.
And also, look at this.
Wait, not this one.
But look at this.
Bam!
That's right.
I can dab.
Let me give you a 360.
A 360 dab.
All for my babe goons.
And also, this is my one that's my favorite.
recognize this one I can't play it on stream because I might
get copyright but don't worry I'll hum it for you guys
See it I told you guys I told you guys it was worth it
delete
Don't you guys?
Wait, what else can I do?
Wait, all these animate, like all these movement, not
animate, movement that I can do.
Look at that.
Whoa.
Oh, here's me shaking my head.
And then, whoa, here's me running.
It's like if I had toast in my mouth instead of a rose, I
gotta catch the bus I can't be late I gotta catch the bus to
see my babe goon can I do it a worm that's a good question I
don't know yeah I'm late oh look at that yeah look at all
these cool cool poses I could do for ya babe I'm not seeing
enough movement oh man wait what else can I do let's see oh
I'm like on the ground now oh
man look at me doing all these poses for all of you guys
here's me getting hit oh man why why won't you go out come
to my birthday party why wait what's this
wait can I I'm a baby I'm a dog.
All right, what else?
Wait, watch this, guys.
Whoa!
Yeah, I took all those lessons just to impress you guys.
Look at that.
Oh, that's right.
A quintuple flip just for you.
Isn't that cool?
I know.
Oh, look at this.
I can even do a handstand.
Oh, that's right.
That's right.
Do you like that?
Wait, watch this.
Cartwheel and the backhand spring.
Cartwheel, backhand spring.
That's right.
get yourself a dog that can cartwheel into a back and spring
so fucking cool anyway here's me dancing yeah here's me
shaking my booty because i know what i got
are you impressed babe
Are you impressed?
What else can I do?
Let's see.
I think this is still my favorite.
Bum.
Yeah, so now you know why I was late.
I was taking all those dance lessons.
And also taking a, getting a nice bath and grooming session.
And then also, you know.
I wanted to like pick you on somewhere special so I chose
the Tokyo Tokyo and I blind floated you and kidnapped you on
the plane and flew you all the way here just so we can be
together on my special day
Anyway, are y'all impressed?
Oh, Zero, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Now I know the reason for how you're his back.
What can I say?
I just love to impress the ladies and men.
why don't you take this lovely oh my gosh my arm wait give
me a sec what happened to okay wait wait i got i think i
gotta fix my arm i might wait i need to fix my arm give me a
sec that's a little awkward
all right give me a sec i gotta fix my arm i dance too hard
I dance too hard, guys.
I'm fixing it.
Don't worry.
All right, there you go.
There you go.
All right.
See, there you go.
Everything's okay.
Arms been fixed.
Guys.
Mr. Broken Bond.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Mwah.
I'm pregnant, dad, and it's yours.
get tested.
I don't think it's mine.
I don't know.
Go get tested.
And then like contact that show where it's like you're not
the father.
That's right.
You can't tie me down like that.
I'm a free animal.
I'm a wild animal.
I'm a free spirit and die.
I won't get tied down.
That's right.
You can't
man i'm a lone wolf that's right wait actually i can make it
so that give me a sec i like this is actually pretty cool uh
look that's right i'm a free wolf no one can tie me down
I got that dog in me.
That's right.
Whoa!
What?
I got some lovely places.
Close your eyes, babe, Goon.
Close your eyes.
I'm going to take you to somewhere special.
The desert.
You might be wondering, where are we?
We're in the desert now.
Okay, wait.
Let me actually take us to somewhere better.
I think we want to spend our Valentine's Day slash my
birthday in the desert.
Uh, where do I want to go?
We took us to Sad Lab.
never escape Sandland.
Where's this?
Oh, now we're camping.
That's right.
Oh my god, wait.
I have an idea.
How do I move myself?
Wait a minute.
Oh, that's awkward.
Wee.
I don't know how to How do I How do I Oh How do I move
myself?
How do I walk over there?
I want to sit down
Well I'm going to sit down I guess I'll sit down on the
floor For now Wait Give me a sec I gotta figure this out
walking.
I gotta figure out how to walk.
Give me a sec.
Uh, this crazy new technology walking.
How does that work?
Wait.
Okay.
Oh.
Okay, wait.
Give me a moment.
I'm trying to figure it out.
how do i how do i move
i'm figuring out how to move guys give me a sec give me a
sec i'm trying to remember how to walk guys it's been a
while it's it's been a while i'm just trying to figure out
how to move I figured it out.
Give me a sec.
Guys, I figured it out.
There you go.
Okay, watch this, guys.
I can sit here now.
Look.
Okay.
Look at that.
i'm sitting here on the table isn't this romantic baby there
you go wait it's so romantic
i'm having way too much fun with this new technology that i
have whoa that's how i want to do wait
Now I am upside down.
There we go.
That cool?
Well.
Wait, wait.
There's some new things I can add too.
How do I do this?
Where is it?
Oh, oh, look at this.
Where did I put this?
Where is it attached to me?
Can I?
A special hat for a special boy.
Wait, give me a second.
I gotta get my...
do my biggest smile it's too big it's too big i don't know i
don't know how big this smiley it's too big give me a sec
i'm trying to figure it out it's too big for my head
i don't want to make it smiley oh there it is i see oh shit
now is way too old now it's even bigger 0.2 oh there there
that should be better just yeah thank you for the thank you
guys i appreciate all the little birthday wishes
yay i got a little birthday hat look at that Wait, wait a
minute.
Um, let me get rid of the rose real quick.
Here's my little...
Oh, I also forgot.
I have this.
But...
Yeah.
Go ahead and my little...
My little hat.
We have other stuff too.
Want to see?
Where is it?
Oh, it's so tiny.
Oh, is it so tiny?
Oh, there we go.
Why?
There you go.
Oh, it's too far away.
Guys, do you think it's on my...
Do you think it's on my head, guys?
You think...
My arms!
I can't reach my head!
My arms are too short!
My eyes are too short.
I can do it.
Give me a sec.
There you go.
Yeah.
Oh, I look so cute.
Look at me.
Look.
I look so cute, guys.
Come on.
Yay.
Oh, wait.
So it's like off.
It's not a lot.
There you go.
Hey.
It's my birthday.
Happy birthday to me.
Happy birthday dear.
Don't give her those.
Dad, that's me.
Happy birthday to me.
Yeah!
We have a cake.
Wait, why did I do all that?
Wait, wait.
Redo, redo, redo.
Where do you do?
I need to get my cake.
How do I?
I'm going to add...
Okay.
I'm going to add a cake, too.
Let's see.
I'm going to put it in my hand.
Where is it?
Where did my cake go?
Where's my cake?
Oh, wait.
Here.
Oh!
Oh, that's not the way.
right okay there we go yeah Mike thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you yeah happy birthday yeah yeah wait
let me start better cake how about there we go yeah I think
oh nowhere oh it's okay it's only donkey that's allergic
strawberry not me I'm not I'm just i'm just legit chocolate
and i'll die if i eat it on this oh my gosh that's a whole
wait that's like i ate it okay wait i didn't
here you go here you go babe here's a cake slice for you on
our special day
Here you go, babe.
Oh,
wait.
Oh, wait.
I have something really cool.
Look at this.
Where is it?
Wait, what?
It's you.
Om yam yam yam yam yam yam yam yam it's you
Where's the other thing I wanted to show What's this?
Oh no not that What's the sacrifice?
Oh wait look at this Look at this.
Other than that, what's this?
Oh my, get that!
Oh, what the fuck?
Get that shit out of here!
No, Tachi!
I didn't ask for it.
Oh, shit.
Wait, it's on... It's above me, isn't it?
It's like...
I didn't ask...
You didn't ask for consent!
There was no consent there.
I'm trying to, oh, here you go.
Ah!
No!
Here you go, this is what I wanted.
Look, I'm mining.
I'm mining, guys.
I didn't even need to be a little bit shorter.
It's time.
Mine and craft.
First, we mine and then we craft.
Wait, wait, wait, I need to...
Let me put...
Let me see.
I need...
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
It needs to be a little smaller.
It was a little bit too big.
Is that big enough?
Yeah.
There you go.
A big, an above average size mic for an above average dog.
Whoa.
Let's do it.
You know what?
It's time.
Sing a little something special for my babes.
Isn't that right?
All right.
Let's circle around.
sorry there you go all right i'll do it here on the table
i didn't plan for the the serenade part but i figured i just
you know i felt something today out here in the woods with
all you babes
that's right it just it was just so i was just so inspired
you know in the woods
let me see uh i know what to sing i don't i definitely don't
think i definitely think this spot is gonna get uh hit by
monetization and they're gonna take my ads but i know what
to sing for all my babes out there my babe goons out there
it's been a long time since I sang this song.
I most likely only sing one part of this song because I only
remember one line.
Oh, wait.
Someone gave me a better idea and I'm going to steal it as
if I thought of that first.
I'm going to steal your idea now.
now that was a better idea than what i originally had
planned don't worry i got reverb all right i've never sang
this song before so let's try
what the what let the dogs out oh whatever
this part let the dogs
out yeah back to oh well about the course yeah or maybe i'll
let this guy sing because what the mk9 hey but they tell me
a man is part of the party whoa put a woman in front and her
mind behind i heard a woman shout out yes let the dogs out a
dog ain't nothing if you know
if you know how but
I got the
movement who let the dog down who let the dog down I didn't
hide babe It's the dog down.
Yeah, who was it?
Who could it be?
Anyway.
That song was a lot longer than I thought.
Actually, a hundred.
Let's see how far I can go to get water.
I'll be right back, guys.
I mean, I'll still be here, but like, I'll be right back.
water and now dad's got to sit down i have to i have to get
my walkies you know
i have to get my walkies all right and i'm gonna see another
song we need the perfect place to sing our next song guys
give me a sec uh don't worry guys i have a perfect place for
our next song.
I think it's here.
Was it here?
Oh shit, yeah.
I mean, there's a better place though that I found just for
us.
Where the fuck am I?
Where am I?
I'm floating out in the galaxy.
I'm just floating out in the galaxy.
like see okay wait there was a place that i wanted to go i
might need a okay or i could go what about here oh this is
nice the space dimension wait all right wait let me let me
find a nice place for us uh where is it i think i forgot to
download it real quick don't worry I'll just download it now
I just don't worry I can just download it now that's the
best part where is it it was pretty cool oh it was this
there it is I might need a cough drop right now I got my
cough drop so I can stop coughing.
Wait, maybe it's this.
Oh, it's, wait, it's this.
Why didn't that show up?
Hello?
Oh.
Why didn't that show up?
That was the thing I tried to do.
We won't understand it because you can't see it, but there
was this really cool place I like found and then it didn't
show up and I'm like confused.
But don't worry, I got this.
i got this guys all right i think it was was this what the
where am i water floating particles where is this place
what the fuck what is is this this isn't what i think where
am i what the fuck this isn't what i downloaded
so wait okay wait
okay i don't know how to i don't know why i don't know why
it's just floating particles where
I'm so lost, guys.
I'm so lost.
I'm going back to Italy.
What the?
Oh.
Fucked up.
I think everything was above me.
I think that makes sense.
now no wonder everything was above me that's why I couldn't
find where I was all right now nope that's still still
floating particles where the fuck am I still floating
particles
man i'm just trying to find us a cool place to sing you know
what i fuck it that's fine i'll sing here i just wanted a
cool place to sing for all of you but i think i found it
guys i think i found it all right Oh shit, okay, let me
figure out how to position myself.
There you go.
All right, and then where's the crowd?
Where's the crowd?
Where's the people cheering me on?
Oh, it's just here.
All right, that's cool.
Oh!
Lights!
There!
Where the film is at?
Oh, did you guys see that?
There's flames!
Wow!
Wait, I wanted to sing right here.
Oh my god, I already forgot what song I wanted to sing.
I was so busy.
I was having so much fun fucking around.
I already forgot.
Oh shit.
I already forgot what song I wanted to sing.
Actually, I'm bored of this stage already.
I wouldn't do it here.
If it loads.
Alright.
Wait, where's the prop?
This was supposed to...
Oh, wait, never mind.
God, there's too many stages.
I don't know where to go.
So many choice...
Okay, how about here?
You know what?
This place is pretty cool.
Alright.
yeah
guys I already forgot what song I wanted to sing for you
guys oh I remember now I remember wait wait I actually
remembered I actually remembered okay it's a really good
song um oh shit I didn't want to do that but that's fine
alright well obviously I'm floating in the air and that's a
problem That's a little bit of a problem, let me.
But then I need to be here.
Am I still floating?
I can't tell.
Oh, yeah, I am.
Guys, am I...
You think I'm touching the floor?
There we go.
Okay, I fixed it.
Okay.
there you go
damn look at these camera pans whoa
there you go are you guys ready wait let me make sure i'm
fully calibrated no i gotta i gotta i gotta calibrate again
i gotta fix myself oh forgot to press the button
all right calibrating oh all right almost done
come on yeah
all right fixed i'm i'm fixed now all right this is a very
special song i think you guys are gonna love it but i need
to wear some i know i just picked the stage but next i need
to wear some very special i need to have a special hat on
for this song.
Let me see if I can put it on real quick.
Let me see if I can find it.
Oh, there it is.
Wait, where's my hat?
Okay.
Attach to me.
Attach to the head where is it where the fuck is my hat
hello where did it go oh my god my hat disappeared again
trying to find my hat it's okay I can put another hat on my
hat it disappeared I don't know why it keeps doing that
alright don't worry I I got another hat.
Should be here somewhere.
I downloaded too many things, guys.
I fucked up.
Wait, what's this?
I'm yam, yam, yam, yam.
It is my special day.
Oh, yeah, I have a sledgehammer, too.
So I saw all these stuff, and I was like, what the fuck was
that?
What's this?
All right, let's see.
Oh, there we go.
okay that one's a little too big so let me make it smaller
there we go
oh yeah that's not on my head there you go wait wait oh my
god it's still not on my head yeah oh is that on my head oh
it is now there you go oh my god it's still not really on it
why is it so hard to put on does it need to be smaller or
some shit oh yeah oh shit that's too big okay there oh wait
that's
Guys, is that perfect?
Can't tell.
Oh, shit.
There you go.
And then...
Yeah!
After that, one more prop.
I swear this is the last prop.
Wait, I can have a what?
Oh, my God.
What the fuck is this?
wait
oh wait never mind sorry sorry ignore what I said ignore
that alright alright I have the perfect sign for this let me
pull it up
I just need to blow my nose what is it called is this what
it's called I hope that's what it's called I hope that's
what it's called
Got any grapes?
A man said no, like I said yesterday, we just sell lemonade,
okay?
Why give it a try?
The duck said goodbye.
Then he wandered away, pom, pom, pom.
Then he wandered away, waddle, waddle.
Till the very next day, pom, pom, pom, pom.
My duck walked up to the lemonade.
stand we said to the man running the stand hey bomb bomb
bomb got any grapes the man said look this is getting old i
mean lemon is all we've ever sold why not give it a go the
duck said how about no then he walked away water water then
he wandered away water water then he wandered away
Duck walked up to the lemonade stand and said to the man
running the stand hey bump bump bump got any grapes the man
said it's it if you'll stay away duck I'll glue you to a
tree and leave you there all day stuck don't get too close
duck said adios then he wandered away waddle waddle then he
wandered away waddle waddle waddle still very nice next day.
Bam, bam, bam, bam.
Our dad walked up to the lemonade stand.
He said to the man, running the sand, hey, bam, bam, bam,
bam.
Got any glue?
What?
No, wow.
Oh, and one more question for you.
Got any grapes?
Bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam.
And a man just stopped and he started to smile.
He started to laugh.
He laughed for a while.
He said, come on, Duck, let's walk to the store.
I'll buy you some grapes so you won't have to ask anymore.
So they walked to the store and the man bought some grapes.
He gave one to the duck and the duck said, Hmm, no thanks.
We know what sounds good.
We make my day.
You think this star, you think this star, you think this
star, has a need.
Lemonade, then he whirled away, whirled, whirled, whirled,
whirled, whirled, whirled
Yeah, actually, I should get wireless headphones honestly at
this point, I was like trying to turn around And then like
my wires got caught up and everything and I was like, bro, I
should really get wireless headphones Or Doki should really
get wireless headphones
I was just like, fuck, how do I get, I actually took off my
headphones and just walked away.
Let me, no more hat.
Hat, God.
I want you guys to look into my eyes, my beautiful eyes.
I actually wandered away.
To the very next day.
Bump bottom.
Wait, let's see if we...
Wait, do we have this song?
My very specialized.
That's crazy.
Wait, there's no way they don't have it.
They should.
Oh, wait.
It's called...
It's one word.
We actually really want to sing this song.
I think it's the perfect sign.
Oh.
I only have this, but I actually don't know how to sing
this.
Wait.
I don't know what to sing.
Since it's Valentine's Day.
I'll sit.
Let's see.
Let's see if I have a background for this, too.
okay wait wait wait wait let me see if i have a background
for this special occasion also i need to put on this all
right this and then i'll put on this for my babes for all my
babes out there and then uh let me see if i can find it let
me see i can find this special place
really just want to find a very special place for us guys
just trying to find a really special place for this special
song I swear it'll be so worth it Let's see.
Oh, I just need to find it.
It has to match the mood that I'm trying to set up for.
All right, I'll sing here.
I'll sing it here.
It's going to be so romantic.
Okay.
uh where is it where did i what's where is it it's gonna be
so romantic but i gotta find it first where the fuck is it
actually hello oh is it this oh no not here no i was here
already i was Did it not download yet?
I mean, this is a cool place, so...
Oonce, oonce, oonce.
Oh, wait.
It's still downloading.
All right, give me a sec.
It is actually downloading.
All right, I found it.
Oh, my God.
Make this a little smaller.
Oh, wait.
That's me smaller.
What the fuck?
oh my god i'm just in space
guys i don't think this is the perfect place i imagine it'd
be i i'm just in space all right how about how about all
right fine but i'm gonna settle i'm gonna settle this might
not be my first choice This might not be my second choice,
but this is a choice.
It's just a choice.
Into the void.
All right, here we go.
Actually, no, that doesn't fit.
You know what?
Fuck it.
We'll go here.
This was my initial.
choice you know it's cute it's pretty cute I will say we
should be able to zoom in
more all right
all right got a special song for you babes it's dedicated to
all you babe goons out there let me second
all right don't worry babe
bump bump bump bump fly me to the moon let me play a the
stars let me see what string is like on Jupiter and Mars in
other words hold my hand in other words baby kiss me
Let me sing forevermore.
You are all that I long for.
I'm worshiping the door.
In other words, please be true.
Yay, babe, I'm talking about you.
You are all that I long for a lot In other words, please be
true In other words, in other words
You.
Yeah, that song is dedicated to you.
That's right.
I'm talking to you, all of you.
Yeah, I'm talking, I'm looking at you right now.
Me?
Yeah.
Only you.
And you.
All right.
Karaoke session is over.
I got a hodge right now.
Hello.
Oh my gosh, I'm having way too much fun.
I guys enjoy my birthday.
Guys, guys enjoy my birthday party.
You got your own very own.
You got your very own dad concert of two songs.
Wait, no, three songs.
Wait, how many songs does?
I said three songs.
That's right.
three whole songs
oh yeah oh yeah the reason why we were all so late was
because we were trying I was trying to figure this out you
know my new fangle technology of walking outside and I was
asking our local rigger like to help and then they
accidentally sent me the wrong file where I couldn't move my
face so like I spent two hours trying to figure that out or
like an hour and a half being like why can't I move my face
I was trying to do tech support and like figure figure it
out like re watching so many videos and stuff um and and
then like and then like the thing was I was sent the wrong
file where the file had no face rigging
the file had no face movement like at 6 p.m at exactly 6 p.m
i figured it out that there was no face rigging and then and
then i was just like oh and i was like um sorry could you i
think you forgot to add yeah sorry gotta look young you know
i'm getting older so i I got some Botox and it sort of
fucked me up.
Yeah, that's why it also took a while.
All right, let's swap environments.
I'm just enjoying playing around with this right now.
I'm having, wait, it's like new toy.
So I can be eternally young.
New toy.
Oh yeah, here.
You want to come to my apartment?
Yeah, that's right, babe.
my apartment wait we don't want to sit yeah that's right
this is my apartment babe you like it
yeah all right I gotta move myself now
there you go god I look so cool yeah Yeah, I brought you
over my place.
See?
Wait, wait, I can actually have you here.
Give me a sec.
Oh, wait.
Look at this.
It's a balloon.
It is just a balloon.
Wait, where is it on?
No, stop.
Why is it on me?
Wait, put it on my...
Actually, put it on my...
Oh, shit.
Why is it like that?
Well, I might have to delete that.
Oopsie.
New toy.
Wait, what is this?
Oh, wait, never mind.
I need to download something else to make this work.
Okay, wait.
New toy.
I'm trying to find it.
Oh, my God.
Oh, it's because it's on my hat.
Yes!
a balloon it's a really up balloon but it's a balloon oh
yeah i can't yeah just for you babe
look at that yeah
i got a balloon yeah What else can I have on my head?
Here's a gift for you.
Just for you.
Unless it's for me.
Oh, here's the key.
To my heart.
Yeah, go, babe.
Begun.
A key to my heart.
Why am I having to fix myself again?
Mother arm ain't working so well.
My other arm ain't work.
Wait.
I mean, it sort of is.
And then I also have...
Babe.
Will you be my dog sitter?
Wait, actually, could I?
Babe.
you do me an honor of being my dog city
I can have multiple dog cities oh my god yes
we're not there You came over to my place.
You mean we're not there yet.
How many birthdays have you spent on me?
We're practically engaged.
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh, my God.
There's that.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
Why is this so shiny?
Oh, and then there's a bear here, too.
Oh,
I'll be honored, Dad.
Oh, my God.
There's so many dads to go around.
Thank you, Melissa, for chat.
Broken pod.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, it's this.
Oh, it's a love letter for me.
What does it say?
I'm out.
having way too much fun.
Oh, wait.
This one's my favorite.
Look at this.
Not this one.
This one's my favorite.
I thought it, like, fit in me so well.
Well, not me, but, I mean, it could be me, too.
What the...
I wonder what does it say.
She fell for it again.
Okay.
I found this.
I was like, oh, I can't believe they have this.
But it's been fun.
Oh my God.
I'm glad.
Baby Gooms, I'm spending my birthday again.
With all my babes today.
It's always a nice, a nice, this.
I love, I love February 14.
I'm not going to spend it all.
today mr.
McLaughlin's thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you Wow fell for you again a word goes to me nice all right
let me see props let me add you guys here
Oh, there you go.
What the fuck?
Where are you guys?
Where do you guys go?
Hey.
Hello.
Hello, dragon.
Yay!
Oh, shit.
You're attached to me.
What the fuck?
What the fuck are you attached to me?
Oh, there we go.
There you go.
That's much better.
That's you.
That's you right there.
I might have fixed this again.
Do I?
Where's my arm?
Is my arm okay?
Nah, it's fine.
I just gotta swap my angles.
There you go.
Look.
You know what's left.
It's dinner time.
Me hungry.
Oh, yeah.
No, I have to fix myself.
Give me a sec.
Oh, yeah.
100%.
Wait, unless...
Wait.
I can fix it.
Wait, what?
Oh, there we go.
Yeah, there you go.
I fixed it.
Yeah, let me fix it.
Now I need to fix the camera.
There's so many things to fix.
I'm so bad at controlling the camera.
There you go.
Yeah, I get to be on the couch.
Yeah.
She never lets me up on the couch.
But not today.
I'm not chaperoned.
That's right.
She can't stop me.
No chaperones today.
That's right.
My day.
My birthday.
Which means Valentine's Day belongs to me.
That's fucking right.
Yeah
Yeah It is my special day you're spending my today with me
not toky me
I'm just having fun I'm having fun being able to move my
entire body you know he's stuck in one position for so long
now you get to see how expressive I am you know yeah yeah
yeah you know what we gotta be out side for this.
I shouldn't be roughing it out.
Get it?
Out here.
And I gotta be in the like inside.
I gotta be out in the wild.
I'm a wild dog.
This feels this feels way too nice.
This feels way too nice.
I need to be out into nature.
Nature cause for me.
Oh my god, is that butterfly?
was that a fucking butterfly yeah maybe oh yeah yeah baby
out here in the forest that's my domain
I'm a wild dog yeah rough rough
Look at these poses.
Bring it.
Bring it on.
Look out for the...
Where?
That's right.
Oh my gosh.
This is not comfortable.
I've been...
belly yeah because I'm well fed see that I mean see that I'm
well fed I'm a spoiled doggy damn right I'm a spoiled doggy
here I like turning around I think it's funny when I
What is it?
Do I look like?
I want to see if I walk into the grass.
Just walk into the grass.
But I'm so far away!
And then I can be...
I can be closer!
And then, watch this.
Oh my god, why am I getting lower?
Yeah.
I barely moved.
Wait, do I disappear when I...
What happened to me when I went to get water?
What happened to me?
Yeah, I'm like, am I sinking?
Wait, they have a pool.
Wait, let's go to a pool.
You just walked there.
Oh, I didn't.
Wait, let me see.
I can walk away.
How far did I go?
Did I go pretty?
far.
Water, water.
Any water the way.
Till the very next day.
I touched the grass.
Yay!
I get to touch grass.
Let's go.
Any water, water, water.
Any water the way.
Alright.
Wait.
Okay.
We gotta go the pool i want to show you guys the pool let's
all go to the pool today
i saw the pool we gotta go there
pool pool when you sit down it's like a mirror cat you know
i'm like
dig a tunnel dig dig a tunnel tunnel take a tunnel take take
a tunnel he has to yeah wait wait that's how the song goes
from lion king one and a half wait let me see that's one of
my favorite songs
but yeah that's how it goes it's like what's that what's
that what was that where we're buying a come
Take a tunnel, take a tunnel, take a tunnel, take a tunnel,
take a tunnel, quick before the hyena come.
Oh, take a tunnel, take a tunnel, take a tunnel, take a
tunnel, take a tunnel, quick, quick before the hyena come.
For those who never heard of this, this is one of my
favorite songs of Lion King One and a Half.
Alright, wait.
What's that?
Quick before the hyena come.
This should just be the rest of the chat.
Take a tunnel.
Okay, wait.
What is that?
Oh, yeah.
The pool.
Let's go to... Wait, actually, the beach or the pool.
Actually, we can do both, honestly.
Let's go to the pool first.
And then we'll go to the beach.
Let's all go to the beach today.
The way I'm okay, guys.
I'm okay.
Wait.
I'm just... I'm like Jesus.
I'm like... I can float.
holy that's a big ass oh you're not allowed in the pool your
pools close pools close guys you're not allowed here it
doesn't even look like what is there no water in the pool i
can't tell guys i was gonna pop i was gonna be like oh i'm
swimming i'm swimming But it looks like there's no water in
the pool.
Yeah, pool is closed.
Pool is closed.
I guess we'll just go to the beach then.
If the pool is closed, I guess we can go to the beach.
I wonder why they closed the pool.
Beach time.
That's fine.
We still have the beach.
It's me and my, me and my babes.
Where the fuck is the beach?
Oh, there it is.
Beach!
Oh my god, I'm in the sand.
Oh, oh, it's okay.
Alright.
Wait.
I'm mad.
I want to go swimming.
I'm almost there, guys.
We're so close to the beach.
We're almost there.
Oh, shit.
That's also me.
We're so close to the beach.
Sorry.
Rough.
We're almost there!
I just want to be at the beach!
Oh my god.
God, it's so white over there.
Let me maybe here.
Yay!
I'm swimming.
I'm swimming now.
Look at me.
Okay, wait.
Somebody's trying to come in.
And it's me.
Alright.
That's me.
Fly away.
I'm swimming!
Are you good?
There you go.
How far?
There I am.
Hello.
Oh shit.
Can you even see me wave?
As me.
Whoa.
Wait, where did I go?
Wait, can I be at the...
Can I stand here?
I want to go sit on the chairs now.
He's so tiny.
That's me.
Oh, wuff, wuff, wuff Wuff Wuff
I'm just barking again Wait, actually can I naturally wait
Wait a minute
Hey guys wait
Try a second how do I roll?
rotate.
I want to sit on this chair.
I don't know if I can rotate myself.
Can I?
Like, I want to sit on this chair, but I can't.
I guess the only way I can sit on it is like this.
Yeah.
Just turn around.
monitor yeah it's my birthday yeah whip let me uh i'm idea i
have another amazing idea i always have such beautiful ideas
guys and then where is it where did it go
why does it always spawn there
why does it always spawn there why can't it spawn anywhere
else all right
no i want you to not oh my god where did my cake go again
i just want to be next to me
Where did my cake go?
It disappeared.
Oh, there it is.
It keeps disappearing.
Okay, wait.
I'm trying to get it closer to me, but I don't know where I
am.
Where am I?
Where the fuck am I?
Oh, that's a plane.
You guys see that?
That was a plane over there.
I flew above me.
But how can I celebrate my birthday if I don't have a cake
to celebrate it with?
Sad.
So sad.
I'm so sad now.
I guess I'll just attach it to my head.
Oh.
I
just wanted to be next to me.
It feels so weird having a whole cake here.
Whoa.
Regret.
Oh, there you go.
Yay.
Let's make a birthday wish.
Oh my gosh, if I can't fucking...
Okay, I'm grabbing a slice.
This cake is too big.
There you go.
A slice is easier to manage.
God, is it?
It's like a shield.
Oh, don't worry, my lady.
Stand behind me.
Oh, my God.
This is...
That's a kickbox now.
Oh, this.
Oh, hey.
I was to have a happy birthday, though.
Yeah.
All right.
This is the best I can do.
it's a shield now seeing a happy birthday to me guys for my
special day happy birthday oh oh you guys want actually you
guys want to see the cake that the cake that i got today
doki took me to a the groomers and it also was like half a
cake shop and then she got me this cake wait let me you see
i can it's pretty cute we're gonna have a photo shoot later
when she's not a lazy piece of shit i'm doing her streaming
for her i'm literally streaming for her what is she doing
huh i hear you yeah you're so spoiled that's right look at
this
yeah i got a cake that's my cake you see that but it's like
newer this one was a display cake though this is a display
cake so like there were still i didn't eat the dog treats by
the way i i didn't
I didn't eat the dog treats.
So this was at the split.
And then it's like, it's newer.
And all the dog treats were there.
I don't know what's in it.
I just know it's dog same.
That's right.
They're happy birthday to me.
It's my birthday.
Happy birthday to me.
Wait, I want to stand up for this.
That's right.
Happy birthday to me.
Happy birthday dear dad.
Yeah!
It's my birthday.
whoa wow all
right no mercy wolf sorry I'm having way too much fun
I had to blow my nose yeah I can't wait to I'm yam yam yam
yet later I'm yam yam that cake later that's fucking right I
gotta reset real quick so I can look at you guys there you
go yeah now I'm back to normal I don't want to judge that
sometimes it like resets myself so I have to do this again
yeah what the fuck oh oh yeah sit on the well i actually sit
on the bench
but yeah
all right thank you everybody for coming to my birthday
party did you guys have fun are you oh my god clap my hands
guys i can clap my hands
wait wait wait wait let me i think we gotta wait oh oh
All right, all right, all right, all right.
But I fucking love that.
Go, dad, go.
All right, wait, wait, wait.
You can't end it with this, though.
We gotta end it with.
We gotta end it with this.
Hoorah!
Yeah!
Wait, which was this?
Move it!
Yeah!
Those dad's lessons are killing it!
I knew those dad's...
Oh, wait, wait, watch.
Look at this.
Bum, bum, bum, bum.
Woo-hoo!
That's right.
All me.
Look at him go.
Look at me, go.
What are you doing?
talking about.
Look at me go.
That's right.
Bam!
Oh, shaking me.
That's right.
I got those moves.
Oh, yeah!
And then my favorite one.
I'm very entertained by myself.
I just entertained myself a lot.
What do you mean, Doki?
It's Dad!
This is me!
i'm doing it oh wait i can do this though for those who are
wondering what else i can do for those who are wondering i'm
very talented by the way wait is this i'm very very talented
because i i
can also do wait i'm not moving
I can also, oh my god, you guys might know this dance, but I
can also go
Hey Macadino, I can also do
How does the song go yet?
Hey, y'all.
Boy, it's Team Fortress 2 again.
We're back to...
We're back to TF2.
Rasputin.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no.
Oh, I got the...
Lover of the Russian Queen.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
Quick, join me behind me!
And then, of course, the classic.
It surprisingly works so well.
it really does it's a pretty it works so well but as always
this is the one that's my favorite but yeah
oh that was fun that was really new toy that's why I hope I
figured, you know, now, now that I'm, now that I'm fully, I
can fully go outside now, move my entire body, not even Joki
can do this.
Well, she can soon, but because I was like her, I was like
the guinea pig, the experiment, and it worked, it worked.
Oh my god, it was very expensive for Sure.
That's my birthday.
See?
I'm so articulated now.
You never seen this in VR.
I told you I'm very expressive when I talk.
I love moving my body.
Yeah.
That's right.
I told you.
That's bright.
You can believe me.
Now you know.
Oh my gosh.
Surprisingly works very well too.
Yeah.
Give him the mic more out.
Often I that's what I'm saying my god.
Why am I the side character?
I deserve I feel like I have main character energy, you
know, I should take over the channel Exactly I was hold my
potential is limitless now now that I'm Unchained I'm no
longer shackled guys That's fucking right.
I'm unchained now.
Look at me.
I can move all four of my legs.
Leg one, leg two.
Look at that.
Look.
Oh my god.
Oh, it's really hard to like lift that up because I'm so...
My legs are so short and I'm so long.
Papa, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Dad VR ringing flood.
Bro, this is better than VR.
I could turn around.
Oh.
Watch that back.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, God.
I'm okay.
Wait.
Oh, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
I'm still young at heart.
Still young at heart, guys.
Still young at heart.
But yeah.
Thank you guys.
Thank you guys for coming to my birthday, everyone.
Thank you.
I hope you guys had.
a fun street hanging out with me today we did a lot we
traveled around the world we went to went to the beach we
went to the pool we went back at my place
we we went back at my place i took you to tokyo oh my god
see i outdo myself every year i really do right babe last
year i didn't take you around the world but now look look at
that babe look at that oh wait wait wait wait i forgot the
ring give me a sec
give me a sec babe
will you Do me the honor of being my dog sitter for the rest
of your life.
That's right.
I didn't hear an answer back in the apartment, so I got to
ask again, you know, at the beach.
yes oh my god really nice that's pretty sick not gonna lie
oh shit that's pretty sick sweet that's fire guys bro he
said he said yes
yay food.
Free place to crash, guys.
Look at that.
Party at my dog sitter's place.
Yes, nice sick, dude.
Everybody!
She said yes.
Party at my dog sitter's place, guys.
Everyone!
Come on!
Let's go!
I know like I had like 20 times where I was trying to end it
but I'm just having way too much fun honestly I don't know
I'm just having way too much fun God when is Doki gonna get
her fucking 3d debut and she can do all of this oh my god
look I'm man spreading
sorry sorry all right all right i'm for thanks thanks you
everyone for for coming to my to my birthday party i had a
great time babe goons every year celebrate whenever i get a
chance just you and just you and me together babes it's
always a great time but we don't tell doki okay don't tell
her what we've been doing she thinks i she thought i ran
away but i'll come back i also used her credit card to go to
tokyo but don't tell her that don't tell her that guys we
had our own special little You and me, that's right, I'm
talking to you.
That's right, babe, Goon.
Just you.
It's our little secret.
Because if you snitch, we won't be able to have our special
little play dates.
Anyway, guys.
Thank you all for coming in for enabling all of us.
this I had a great time I had a great time everyone and as
always stay hydrated posture check get up and move I'm
sitting down right I should get up actually if I'm gonna do
this wait wait this I've always wanted to do this all right
all right as always everybody like oh my god so cool
As always, wait, wait, wait, wait, okay.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check.
Get up and move around.
Get that blood flowing.
And if you, and if you,
You, sorry, sorry.
And you stayed up for me and it's a bad because you deserve
it.
Bye-bye, everyone.
Happy birthday to me.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, before I go, before I go,
guys, before I go, we have to do one more thing.
Bump, bada, bada, bada.
Wait, wait, wait, no, that's not the last thing we're doing,
but I like that.
That was the default.
But before I go, we gotta do...
Wait, gotta do.
Boom!
That's right.
Oh, yeah!
Cartwheel!
Backflip!
Bye-bye!